[Inaudible] do I snuck it?
[inaudible] E um,
on fed into Wilson and hide, hide,
hide.
[inaudible] yeah.
[inaudible].
Yeah, over here we talk that some hell it's English man,
or believe it stir
[inaudible] intensely Snapple. Most of my hands
[inaudible] at soccer routine can handle their own way. Liga, hinder.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible].
Yeah. [inaudible] yeah.
[inaudible] yeah. Yeah. So the idea that fresh to me now
[inaudible] needs the eminent
[inaudible] yeah.
[Inaudible] uh, some of
[inaudible], uh, Oak, uh
[inaudible] or Eaton live demand, CWC
men. Uh [inaudible].
But do you heard [inaudible] or sense or
[inaudible] [inaudible] it's not men in the war. So are you somewhat
[inaudible] also when dog, so
[inaudible] till Auschwitz, uh,
that that's sort of our store
[inaudible] uh, [inaudible].
There is water fish, two men
[inaudible] [inaudible] leave it in [inaudible].
So for Chet,
the man for shambling the Interborough men,
my [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] and
[inaudible] out for me. [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] so [inaudible] mid the ad.
[inaudible] the [inaudible] at foremost,
the thing I say [inaudible].
Do comment
[inaudible] audiences to tailor, uh, Auschwitz. Uh
[inaudible].
[Inaudible] in looked
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] standard
in Fisk ma and Bhutan.
So store some [inaudible] or
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
did real good. [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] some months
[inaudible] may last bill don't Congo.
[inaudible] [inaudible] from there. They don't come from,
so [inaudible] not this.
So the first time.
Well, then to scan some dilemma to that there, how do you see it in
[inaudible]? Yeah, some, uh
[inaudible].
Who.
Played the juice? Some
[inaudible] [inaudible] some boys
[inaudible].
[Inaudible] or, uh
[inaudible] or, uh,
there was small Maskcara difficulty yet,
or they were interested summer Horning there and
the
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] democracies, some,
some domain, three dog further out.
Dean adjusted some new for chatter reliever. Awesome.
Just knocking Movado,
beacon petite as if he couldn't for dye ELL switch.
[Inaudible] list for us. Uh, [inaudible] health nurse, Logan
[inaudible] Papo occupation.
So [inaudible] for [inaudible].
[Inaudible] all of this or not. I stuck it tail.
Uh [inaudible] over at
[inaudible] [inaudible] uh.
[Inaudible] [inaudible] or what are you going to get in? Be RBF, meaning
[inaudible] [inaudible] or for art? Moscow? No, there, so, yeah,
the [inaudible] will be
[inaudible].
I did. I added a thing [inaudible]
integrate [inaudible].
[Inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] school or not stay new Frogger or, uh,
uh [inaudible] or,
uh, this shins in, uh,
through good song. FL Butte now, so don't
[inaudible].
[Inaudible] um,
[inaudible] [inaudible].
Yeah, I'll say over 50 Auschwitz
[inaudible] [inaudible] or
[inaudible] [inaudible] to Bergen-Belsen audience. Just about four children.
[inaudible].
But who've heard [inaudible].
Y'all believe shift key Bergen Belsen your gig. Uh,
first
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] or
[inaudible] or a
[inaudible] or, uh,
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] or
[inaudible] or Dave, are you doing
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible].
How about you have to say I tailor their main. They do say
[inaudible] [inaudible] and heroine, but not to say I'm at
[inaudible] among I would face a shadow in team. They do say, Hey,
and then I made him a clue
[inaudible] [inaudible] demagogue as cake today. [inaudible].
[Inaudible] [inaudible] uh [inaudible] um,
how about at the tone of the audit?
[inaudible] Oh yeah. [inaudible] so hard, man.
To scope it field [inaudible] to scope it to him.
We are to scope it to [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] I can't think of it. [inaudible]
recording now.
[inaudible] [inaudible] intellect.
How do, how do I help the murderer?
[Inaudible] y'all have no [inaudible].
[Inaudible] fire to some conduct code.
[Inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] so don't be hollering.
Make war water, or, uh, there,
there, you know, we have
[inaudible] [inaudible] so
[inaudible] some [inaudible] or
[inaudible] soccer, then they believe in that now.
[Inaudible] [inaudible] do HOD. Who,
who said, [inaudible].
Sorry. Lit from your soils here
then [inaudible] are
[inaudible] and [inaudible] own vent. You'll see,
in the smart there's song angle is to
when there are
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] so there,
there the official Carol or
[inaudible] Lee character, or they can be some there intake
[inaudible] [inaudible] at
[inaudible] [inaudible] example. [inaudible] this summit,
this summit son probably will learn.
All three solid takes is theater. It is sun.
So the, the, the heavily, we think consti that
[inaudible] for [inaudible] saw the TV. Got it. They
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] champion moot. We are
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] the
[inaudible], uh, men prolonged 60.
They will produce from the sea [inaudible] or
redone, uh, for, from an old dog,
some interactive
[inaudible] disc [inaudible] or
[inaudible] compass.
The Ohio
[inaudible] [inaudible] yeah. Uh, have to do
[inaudible]. Uh [inaudible].
Do you mean
[inaudible] through there or, uh, mean through
[inaudible] or, uh,
[inaudible] that bookstores through under men then through
[inaudible].
[Inaudible].